Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Marvel Eternals video
Marvel dropped a bunch of new
information about the movie bunch of new
details and preview so we'll break it
down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs for x-men and how they're
world-building in big cosmic ways in the
MCU going into Marvel phase 5 there's
even a funny clip from Kit Harington
talking about the movie because he did a
recent Q&A on Twitter so I'll include
that clip in the video too if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with kit harington's
black knight character in the next big
Avengers 5 movie so just going down the
list starting with number 5 everybody
wondering how they're going to use the
Marvel Eternals movie to set up the
x-men characters in Marvel phase 5
because it is going to be a while before we
see the really big x-men characters show
up in the way that they do show up will
be very different from what we saw
during the Fox Marvel x-men movies the
Eternals characters were created by the
Celestials they're immortal functionally
so they live forever where have they
been this whole time there are a lot of
questions that Marvel has to answer in
this movie but in the way that Marvel
sort of leaves in characters like a
tapestry connecting everything the
Marvel eternals will be connected to all
the other pre-existing Marvel movies in
sort of a retroactive easter-egg seeming
kind of way like it's all been connected
this whole time they've been around this
whole time they've been influencing
things this whole time we just haven't
known about it till now one of the
things that connects all this though is
the Infinity stones which we just got
done dealing with during the Infinity
Saga
during the Infinity Saga we learned the
origin of the Infinity stones from the
collector which is also happening on
nowhere the head of one of the dead
Celestials in present day obviously the
Celestials are going to be some of the
biggest characters literally and
metaphorically during the Marvel
eternals movie just to explain their
backstory and they're also kind of going
to be the next big villains of the MCU
the cool thing that they're doing with
the Infinity stones at least on a story
level during Marvel's eternals movie is
showing you how everything is connected
through the Infinity stones and the
Celestials the bigger cosmic characters
like eternity the purpose of the
universe you hear ego the Living Planet
talked about being born and not really
understanding who he was
well we'll learn a little bit more about
how he's connected how no where and the
other Celestials that we've
seen before are connected to what's
happening during the Eternals movie so
number four a quick history lesson when
the universe was born in the Big Bang
essentially the Infinity stones were the
remnants of the previous version of the
universe that's why they're so powerful
they contained the power of an entire
universe distilled down into six small
stones so what happens is is when the
new version of the universe of the MCU
as we know it is born eternity is also
born with it it creates the Celestials
to go out and garden the universe just
experiment try to create life when it
doesn't work out clear the weeds and try
again
that's how characters like ego the
Living Planet were created but they
don't have a direct link with eternity
they don't speak to it all the time
that's why ego the Living Planet says I
didn't really know what I was when I was
created he was just kind of left to his
own devices just to experiment and
figure things out so even though they're
not meant to be good or evil characters
you do have rogue Celestials that's kind
of what ego was when he tried to turn
the entire universe into himself but
what happens millennia ago is that the
Celestials come to Planet Earth they see
that life has sprouted and they try to
experiment on it creating the Eternals
granting them cosmic powers effectively
turning them into a bunch of super
humans as you saw during the collectors
PowerPoint presentation that he gave the
guardians of the galaxy on the history
of the universe
you saw that the Celestials like this is
east on the searcher on a different
planet using the Infinity stones in
their task so the Celestials used
infinity stone cosmic energy to give the
Eternals their powers that's why some of
the powers in these previews look
similar to some of the powers of the
characters in present day who got their
powers from Infinity stones really good
example is Richard Madden's Icarus
character who can wield cosmic energy
look at the light bloom on his hand it
looks just like the light bloom on
Captain Marvel when she's using her
powers she got her powers from the space
stone just another one of the Infinity
stones another really good example is
Salma Hayek's a Jack character she's the
leader of the Eternals she has magical
powers kind of like the ancient one or
dr. strange in back in December Kevin
Feige showed off an eternal trailer at
Brasil comic-con they haven't released
it online but during that footage
she was wielding magical glyphs that
looked just like dr. strange magical
glyphs when he was fighting Thanos
costume designs also seem very similar
to the modern Avengers
two designs those are all things that
Marvel is doing to show you how
influential the Eternals characters have
been to everything that's happened in
human history yet somehow we haven't
seen them till now so obviously that's a
big part of the story too where have
they been this whole time why did they
participate in the big battle during
avengers endgame in what's going on with
kid Harrington's Black Knight character
they Kevin Feige has said it's so big
that he's going to star in one of the
next Avengers movies
so when present-day Kit Harington is
playing Dayne Whitman he's not the Black
Knight yet he's just a regular
archaeologist that's part of this long
lineage of the Black Knight the way they
talk about it he's going to have a black
knight arc through the course of the
film and will slowly become the comic
book black knight by the end but he's
not going to start out like that he'll just
be a normal archeologist learning about
the tomb quote-unquote of the space gods
which is actually taken directly from a
Jack Kirby Eternals comic book the tomb
of the space guys within Marvel lore is
really just a place that the Eternals
can go to contact the Celestials to
summon the celestial host that's where
you get into the larger machination zin
the villains of the film the real
villains even though technically they're
saying that the deviance or the villains
of the Eternals movie technically
they're not really it's actually the
Celestials so him learning about the
Celestials is sort of this event on the
level of the earth learning the aliens
exist like during the first Avengers
movie so the turtles don't want him
messing with the Celestials or revealing
their secrets to the world you've all
seen the set pictures of Gemma Chan's
searcy character with his character they
have a sort of romance during the film
she's the one that actually tries to
stop him from revealing everything but
then they wind up falling in love they
had a big romance in the comics so I'm
assuming that they're just going to do a
version of their comic book romance they
haven't fully explained how he becomes
the Black Knight during the movie but it
probably has something to do with him
embracing his family's legacy in the
actual evany blade itself the way they
explained his Black Knight armor during
the movie is that a lot of it's going to
be CG because when they were actually
filming it they didn't have a completed
script and they hadn't completely
finished building his armor so they're
kind of doing it the Robert Downey jr.
Iron Man armor way where Robert Downey
jr. rarely walks around in actual
physical armor on set usually they just
do all of his armor in post-production
my assumption is that they're just going
to tie the armor to the actual blade
like he'll hold the blade and activate
the armor that way and it'll look
little bit like when Black Panther
activates his nano vibranium armor or
Iron Man's nano armor the blade itself
is actually really badass the ebony
blade can teleport just like Thor uses
the Bifrost and Stormbreaker except he
doesn't need to be holding the blade
itself to teleport he's connected to the
blade on a magical level so he can
teleport to the blades location even if
the blade is on the other side of the
earth or if it's on another planet it's
nearly indestructible it can cut through
adamantium in vibranium and it can
deflect magical attacks this will all be
useful stuff for when he's fighting the
Eternals characters who have grand
cosmic power they're crazy powerful then
because he can use it to counter all the
Avengers powers they can have a little
bit of fun with that when they get to
Avengers 5 probably the greatest power
that the blade has though is that Merlin
enchanted it so that any time that the
Black Knight is in contact with it he's
virtually immortal he cannot be killed
in battle which comes in very handy the
way they balance all those powers out
though is the blade itself is cursed
like they talk about the curse of his
family the more he wields the blade in
battle the more people he kills with it
the more it becomes tainted by evil and
the more he succumbs to bloodlust and
eventually he would turn into a monster
if he just kept killing people with it
the way that the Eternals movie is
setting up Marvel's new x-men characters
or x-men movies the mutants however you
want to think about them is all through
the Celestials their cosmic power and
how they've changed the earth and the
Eternals in humanity when the Celestials
created the Eternals on earth they also
left trace elements of their DNA their
cosmic power in the soil that slowly
tainted the earth so eventually it
modified human DNA creating the X gene
the reason why we haven't seen a lot of
mutants till present day is just because
the X genes have not been activated
that's where you get into the concept of
all the cosmic energy that's released
through Santos's Infinity Gauntlet snaps
to Hulk's snap in an Iron Man snap you
have three Infinity Gauntlet snaps in a
relatively short time span all on planet
earth the way they talked about it
during avengers endgame is that just a
single Infinity Gauntlet snap releases
cosmic energy on a scale never before
seen in the universe
now imagine that happens three times in
the span of a couple years that's more
than enough to activate everyone's X
genes
all over the planet which is why you're
not seeing x-men pop up till years after
Avengers endgame the reason why the
Celestials are the secret villains of
the movie though technically secret
villains if you want to call them that
is because of the celestial host because
they will wipe out humanity if they
deemed them to be a failure
press f in the chat for Earth again and
the reason by the Eternals weren't in
this big battle during avengers endgame
is because when this is all happening
between the snaps they still think that
there are normal people their memories
have been altered by one of the other
Eternals sprite who has the ability to
control people's minds and just like the
cosmic power of the snaps activate a lot
of X genes around the planet those also
trigger the Eternals memory and they
start to remember that they are in fact
immortal in cosmic beings but hopefully
that explains a little bit about what's
going on with the Eternals movie this is
that funny clip of Kit Harington talking
about it he's really pumped up about it
but just like the other actors they
don't tell him a whole lot about what's
going on Tom Hollands style the movie
itself has been delayed till February
next year just because of the virus they
bump their Marvel phase 4 schedule but
we will still get a Marvel Eternals
trailer in a couple months if you have
any big questions about what's going on
with the movie or the characters just
let me know in the comments below
but everyone click here for my brand new
Marvel Wolverine deleted scene in Easter
eggs video and click here for my brand
new Mandalorian season 2 video thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!